weirdly part of the target you got hocus
pocus too that's for me i got a little
mermaid a little mermaid and then we
both
have like a pretty beautiful amount of
enchanting yeah yeah yeah
it's good this has been a perfect disney
day for us ladies and gentlemen we have
it the official teaser trailer for the
little mermaid i'm looking forward to it
i'm also looking forward to everyone who
wants to
you know those people on the internet
saw the thumbnail and i was like oh yeah
i remember hearing stuff about that
thing i remember the conversation
surrounding this movie i'm excited for
the comments i'm gonna judge this
trailer solely based off of you know
what the trailer's giving us which i
imagine is reminding me of that great
cartoon
that's gonna be better all right let's
check it out leave a like too
[Music]
holy moly
[Music]
i want to be
where the people are
dude i know it looks like funny neighbor
[Music]
aquaman
oh dinglehoppers and thingamabobbers
[Music]
i goosebumps be
part of that world
i love the little mermaid
i really do yeah there's like a certain
handful of disney movies that i really
grew up watching a lot
and the little mermaid was for sure
one of those films
so
for a nostalgia trailer
this worked on me like nobody's business
yeah that magical anticipation i'm like
oh my god they're bringing it to life
for real yeah this is funny scene
because you know it's like a lot of
animated you know cgi and stuff going
for the real world effect so to see it
sometimes it looks like finding nemo
other times looks like aquaman
that's what the animation blend looks
like there was something just sweeping
about it to me and very moving and
touching i honestly found it just
incredibly touching and i know it's only
because i love the little mermaid but
maybe yeah i am
maybe i am wondering
maybe if i didn't even really have that
fondness for the little mermaid or
hadn't seen it that i might have still
been encapsulated by
the the imagery and and the tone because
it doesn't show you a lot no but i think
that's part of the charm of of this as a
teaser is it draws you in and it just
shows you where it just shows you how
they're realizing the sea and especially
her little you know chamber of
collections you know it gives you just
enough yeah that you can yeah just sort
of feel the aura and the vibe and you
can kind of feel the magic that she must
experience being able to zip in and out
of all these different coves and things
you know it it has a very elemental
quality well that moment in in the movie
because that is such a defining
character point for for aria in that
scene so i felt like just even getting a
little bit of of slow moving on her as
she's singing
getting a look at her body language her
expression because her voice is
fantastic but that sense of longing and
wonder and desire all in her eyes i was
like
i'm weirdly getting a lot out of this
one shot and i don't know if it's my
nostalgia just projecting so much onto
like hey this looks great
or like
because to me it was it was really
hitting and yeah i thought it was
beautiful and i i like uh
like i mean the actual
co i don't care that she's black uh
like the
the actual costume itself
looks a little cosplay to me to be
honest well they gotta make it like a
full tube thing cause they they can't
give her the shells
they would never if it makes no sense to
me if they're gonna take them they're
gonna take the beer out of pinocchio
they got to take the shells out of a
little mermaid it does look it does look
uh to me that it was that was the one
part of it that's like it looks like a
costume yeah it looks like something you
got on the shore on land instead of
something that you made down here
however you know
that is like my one little thing that i
know
when watching it
it's not like watching like weird cgi
you know like maybe this film will have
the official trailer and then i'll be
like a lot of weird
yes we got a little there was a little
we saw flounder from behind but we
haven't seen like actual you know
talking flounder oh i know always by
seth rogen that's
not real i think you should go to the
surface
uh
we have lots to see i know you guys see
triton we got to see ursula and all that
and and like i even like the little
mermaid too really yeah with arielle's
daughter
wow is it good
yeah it is i'm gonna watch it tonight
ursula's sister
no good my daughter my sister my
daughter my sister
yeah i mean that's that's i'm a big
little mermaid i didn't know this about
you people probably wouldn't
expect that from me it's weird but that
is my jam i thought i loved the little
mermaid i thought that was a great film
that's probably
the girl
like that's one of the disney movies
growing up that i saw the most as well
and that i always had on and yeah this
did give me like i really liked how this
teaser and again i feel like the
official trailer is going to be a
different experience and i'm open to
that but i just love the mood and the
aura because this definitely brings you
back to the original but it has this
like sense of space where i was like i
could almost watch a movie where her
heel is just on her own
you know hopefully i mean hopefully one
day we get that john um yes guillermo
del toro's little mermaid well you know
i think the thing is and graham there's
a very specific sequence they're they're
honing in on is that a big part of uh in
the sea it's like it's got to feel very
vibrant and colorful and i don't know
what they're going to be going for with
the animals it looks like they're going
for that like lion king photo realistic
[ __ ] and i feel like you gotta but it's
like you can't go to pinocchio where
it's like it's just like
so animated yeah you know you gotta find
the right there's gotta be some middle
ground jungle book uh there's gotta be
like some kind of middle ground you
gotta find there or else it can look a
little strange yeah so i i think there's
a lot of vfx work that has to be done
and it's disney so you know they're
gonna let them take their time uh
this is a theatrical
are we yeah oh yeah they're
but they will whip crack those animators
way more than they did on pinocchio make
that fish look real
that's not photo real do it again
sebastian doesn't look like a real crab
there's too much facial movement this
does not look like an anthropomorphic
octopus woman take it back so yeah i
think it looks great um i do too what
time period is it in when she becomes a
real girl with legs and stuff yeah black
girl is it gonna be
step into a very racist world
yes
yes and then what's the prince's name
prince philip or whatever he's gonna
eric is this one that's right they all
got
white dude names but prince eric the
best one of them all i know i just
remember his dashing looks but yeah
he'll have to you know start a whole
civil rights movement and that'll take
over the movie
and then uh you know then he'll be
forced to go live in the sea i love this
trailer
i'm really looking forward to it it
looks beautiful i think so too
i am the target market for this and
there's probably like little girls and
like the girls who grew up on this oh no
i'm the great
weirdly part of the target you got hocus
pocus too that's for me
i got a little mermaid little mermaid
and then we both
have like a pretty beautiful amount of
enchanted yeah yeah yeah so it's good
this has been a perfect disney day for
us yeah all right guys thank you for
being here this looks great i'll talk to
you soon
[Music]